foreign
Microsoft introduced a new version of
the Bing search engine that comes with a
chat feature this chat feature uses a
similar technology to the one used in
chatgpt a popular air chat Microsoft
claimed that its chat feature was even
more powerful than chat GPT however it
was later discovered that chat feature
in the new Bing was actually powered by
a new version of the same technology
called gpd4 which is even more advanced
than what Chad GPT uses so while the new
Bing has a chat bot similar to chat GPT
it's actually using a more advanced
technology that makes it even better
than charging so hey everyone welcome
back to another video by simply learn in
this video session we will learn about
Bing chat we'll cover topics like what
is bring chat how to use Bing chat how
to use Bing on your phone examples of
prompts and Bing does Bing uses shared
GPT but before we begin let me ask you a
quick question so which groundbreaking
technology known for its ability to
generate human-like responses is
utilized in the popular AI chatbot chat
GPD option A is gpt1 option b is gpt2
option C is gpt3 and option D is GPT 4.
now you can pause this video and answer
in the comment section so let's start
with the topic what is Bing check Bing
chat is a chatbot experience developed
by Microsoft that uses artificial
intelligence to offer responses to user
queries the technology behind Bing chat
is based on chat GPT version 4 large
language model from open AI which is
known for its ability to generate
responses similar to how humans would
answer the questions unlike a typical
search engine Bing chat is designed to
provide a more natural and
conversational response to user queries
it offers three different formats for
responses that is creative balanced and
precise giving users a range of options
to choose from depending on their
preferences according to Microsoft the
chat feature on the latest version of
Bing has been enhanced by integrating a
Next Generation version of open AI large
language model surpassing the
capabilities of chat GPT this
integration enables you users to ask the
ah chat board a wide range of questions
and receive detail and natural responses
that include footnotes linking back to
the original sources moreover the chat
board can assist with creative tasks
such as writing poetry stories and songs
however experts are working to ensure
that AI technology is protected against
potential cyber attacks highlighting the
urgency of this issue so this was about
being shared now let's understand how to
use beam chat before understanding this
we need to know that currently Bing chat
is exclusively accessible through
Microsoft Edge while there are some
third-party extensions that enable
access to the new Wing via Google Chrome
but they do not have official support
from Microsoft once you have Microsoft
Edge go to the bing.com as normal type
bing.com
here you can access Bing chat in few
different ways here on the top left
corner we have chat we can click on this
and access
then we have this Bing logo on the top
right corner we can access bank chat
from here also
then we have this try it or learn more
below the search bar these two we can
access Bing chat from here also
so when you attempt to access the Bing
chat board without being logged in you
will be asked to log into your account
you can create an account using any
email address including those from Gmail
and Yahoo
so first of all we need to understand
its layout
so let's start we'll click on this try
it
and here it comes
so first we have is this text area
so at the bottom of the screen there is
a space where you can type in your
messages and questions for Bing chat
this place is called the text area the
next we can see is new topic here it is
this new topic so if you click on new
topic while using Bing chat the previous
conversation will be deleted and you
will be asked to start a new one
so this is the text area and this is the
new topic
so whenever we ask a question and we
receive an answer then there are also
sources mentioned in the answer
so when you ask a question Bing uses
conversational AI to provide responses
to your queries unlike traditional
search engines Ming doesn't display
results in a list format but rather
gathers information from web to generate
a response
so we'll ask a question like
what is a machine
all right
it is taking its time searching for what
is machine generating answers for you
so as we can see
these links this mentioned one
and this one these are the sources that
we were talking about
so Bing uses conversational AI to
provide responses to your queries unlike
the traditional search engines
so when you receive an answer from Bing
it also includes links to the sources it
is used to generate that response like
as we can see there are the links this
one and this one these are the links so
basically it generates its answers from
these links
all right so as we can see these
questions so these are known as
follow-up questions so after you get a
response from Microsoft Bing it will
generate suggestions for different
follow-up questions that you can use for
example if you ask Bing what color is
the sky
right it messages the follow-up
questions is the sky blue on other
planets or how does pollution affect the
color of the sky
and as we have asked what is the machine
he's asking like Bing chat is asking
what are some other examples or what are
some examples of simple machines
so this is an example of follow-up
question
so now here upside we have is search
or we can say chat search or chat you
can switch between traditional search
results and the AI chat board by
clicking on either option located at the
top left of the screen
simply
you can see these two
simply click on the one you prefer to
toggle between the two this is search
and this is chat you can toggle between
the two very easily here in the mid we
can see conversation style so one is
creative one is balanced and one is
precise Bing chat is designed to give a
response that feels more like a human
than a regular search engine it provides
the response options more creative more
balanced and more precise
each of these options is
self-explanatory
if you choose more creative you will get
an imaginative and unique responses
sometimes with images
more balanced is similar to chatting
with a friendly and informative human
much like a chat gbt and if you select
mode precise you will get brief and
straightforward answers so it's your
choice which one do you want to proceed
with
more creative more balanced or more
precise
next is prompt counter
so let me ask a question first
all right
so it will give me answer and from that
I'll tell you what are the prompt box
or prompt counter so basically here we
can see 2 of 20. so during our
conversation with Bing you'll notice a
number displayed that keeps a track of
responses you have received so far
note that there is a limit of 20
responses per conversation as we can see
we have already Run 2 of 20.
so these are the suggestions that Bing
gave us
the next is feedback button on this
bottom right corner as you can see so
when scanning the screen you will
quickly notice a feedback button on the
bottom right corner of the chat window
this button lets user provider feedback
to the Microsoft Bing on suggestions or
things they like or dislike with the
option to include a screenshot so this
was the complete layout of the bin jet
also if you want to dive into the
fascinating world of artificial
intelligence and data science look no
further our artificial intelligence
Masters program in collaboration with
IBM is designed to equip you with the
skills and knowledge needed to become a
specialist in rapidly evolving feeling
this program includes industry relevant
courses such as data science and python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
chat GPT and also features of hackathons
and AMA sessions hosted by IBM itself
India you can also have a look at our
learner's Journey which have opted for
these courses we need to keep updating
your skills on a regular basis no matter
what level you're at a recently
completed the professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University and I must say it was very
insane overall I had a wonderful
experience with simply learn the course
material was comprehensive and the
faculty was extremely experienced The
Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning now let's begin and
ask some questions to bring so let's see
I'll ask what is chat GPT
chat gbt is an artificial intelligence
chatbot developed by Ai and released in
November all right so it basically gives
you an answer with the links as we can
see the link number one is here and the
link number two is there you can also
have a look at these links by clicking
on them so it basically gives you
response based on these informations or
articles
which is good all right now let's ask
some of the questions like
write an essay write a short essay
politics
let's see
all right
it's making the paragraphs
so this is a short essay not everything
is is coming from other sources as we
can see this politics to lists lives
this is not from any other source
but this is the other source
and this one is also the other source
all right now let's ask
me a letter
for sick leave
the chat will take care
all right so it is also explaining how
we should write and also it is showing
an example
so all we have to do is to put our name
and address and everything
so it is basically creating a layout in
which we'll have to put in our words
that's it it is pretty similar to chat
GPT
when it comes to this and these are all
the links that we can see and this is a
format of sick leave letter
nice
now let's ask some of the questions like
create
you
all right now let's see
how much time will it take it usually
take more time than chat gbt that thing
I have noticed already but it is fine
it's not a big deal
he's also showing the steps you can
follow to create a text Adventure game
using python
very briefly all right
game all the libraries it is showing
everything it is showing
all right let me ask another question
I'm plan
[Music]
a trip
from Bangalore
to 29
[Music]
suggest me
to face
and what else
for the trip
let's see how it responds
okay the name of the hotels is also
mentioned
all right
so there are several ways to explore
travel from Mangalore to Mana you can
take a flight from Bangalore to Cochin
taxi all right so it is also explaining
the way alternately you can take a bus
from Bangalore to munnar
the journey takes around 10 to 12 hours
which is also true here are some
examples of hotels all right
I'll ask another question follow up
can you add the links of the hotels
so that I can book
all right so it is also adding the links
which is nice
I haven't expected that
let's see if it works or not
pretty far it is not working I believe
let's try another one
here it is this one is working so I
believe the links are working some
mistake would be
in the previous one
all right nice
all right so we have asked some
questions to paint shared so now let's
move on to the next topic which is how
to use Bing on your phone
so Microsoft has recently included Bing
chat in the edge mobile application for
both Android and iOS devices to access
Bing chat you will need to follow these
simple steps download Microsoft Edge
from either Google Play store or Apple
App Store once the app is installed open
it and login to your account or create a
new one if you don't have an account
follow the on-screen instructions
choosing your data sharing preferences
and deciding if you want to make Azure
default browser navigate to bin.com chat
where you will see a welcome message for
the newbing you can use the microphone
or keyboard icons to ask questions or
click sign in and enter your Microsoft
Account Details if prompted finally
select your preferred conversation style
and start chatting with Bing or open
Bing app sign in with your Microsoft
account
click the Bing chat button now to type
out your questions instead of speaking
them aloud click on the keyword button
located at the bottom right corner of
the screen you will be prompted to
choose a conversational style such as
creative balanced or precise once you
have made your selection type out your
questions in the prompt at the bottom of
the page and then click the submit
button if you have additional questions
compose them as necessary and click
submit again to clear the chat and start
over click on the groom icon located at
the bottom left corner of the screen
alright so now let's have a look at some
examples of prompts in bing
so we can use some prompts that will
help us in writing the stuff we want so
we'll now discuss some prompts that can
actually help us in writing whatever we
want or a proper plan or something if we
want to write some table create some
table create some chart Etc
so let's start with the prompt number
one which is create an itinerary so when
embarking on a journey to a let's say
unfamiliar location being a can be
utilized to generate a customize
itinerary
by requesting an itinerary from Bing a
you have the option to include specific
preferences such as affordability
pedestration accessibility public
transportation and more this enables you
to obtain a detailed day by day
itinerary with navigations instructions
promptly for individuals excluding new
destinations being AI proves to be a
valuable tool for swiftly creating a
personalized and convenient travel plan
so let's have a look so we will write
like let's say create an itinerary
so let's say Singapore
let's see how Bank chat responds
so Bing chat is creating a six day
itinerary a four day itinerary
all right it is also attaching some
links as we can see so this Bing chat
can help you plan a trip or something
like that tracking plan or something
somewhere you want to go with your
friends all you have to do is to write
this prompt create an itinerary and you
can also mention the days and the place
you want to go so Bing chat will provide
the whole plan as we can see a 60
itinerary that includes Chinatown
Gardens by the bay they are also
creating these links so we can visit
these links also the sources actually
these are okay then now let's move to
the second prompt which is which will
help you in writing any kind of Articles
blogs Etc
so we can do that like all we have to do
is to write I am writing
now
here you have to mention uh law slash
article whichever you want like let's
say I want to mention
I'm writing an article
animal
welfare
give me uh
five creative ideas
all right so this is the prompt
now let's see how Bing chat will respond
so these are some creative items for
your article on Animal Welfare Point
number one is spread the word about
Animal Welfare issues on social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram second is organizer dog walk
or run to raise money for the animal
shelters third point is volunteer at an
animal shelter and help take care of
animals all right forces hold a
fundraiser for animal shelter fifth is
create a pet care package with toys
treats a dog bed and other items to
raffle off
so these are the ideas that Bing chat
gave me including the links
as you can see
all of these points have the links so
this prompt is for those who actively
writes blogs articles and need new ideas
to create those articles so this prompt
is very helpful in those cases all right
now moving on to the third prompt which
is creating a table
so let's say so if you're conducting a
research
on a topic that can be organized into a
table consider requesting Bing chat to
assist you traditional responses often
consist of lengthy paragraphs but using
a table similar to bullet points is more
effective method of presenting the
information you seek so consider this
scenario you're looking for a new car
and you have managed to narrow down your
options to two choices to Aid in your
decision making process you can request
Bing check to provide an overview of the
two cars or two bikes and format the
results as a table format so now let's
try this prompt once all right so we'll
write
create a table
which is
giving an overview
Royal Enfield
winter 350.
and the other bike let's say
Royal Enfield
meteor
350.
all right now let's see
so being chat is creating a table let's
say
so here is the table of comparison in
Royal Enfield 350 and Royal Enfield
meteor 350.
so the price difference is there mileage
difference is there engine displacement
is also mentioned everything as we can
see if we want to compare two cars two
bikes so let's say if you want to
compare to mobile phones all we have to
do is to use this prompt this will give
you a comparison between these two bikes
mobiles or anything anything like cars
Etc whichever you want to buy and you're
confused like if you want to buy one
thing or the other so it will also refer
to some things like as you can see bike
they go 1991 wheels.com you can also
check out these links also but basically
it gives you a whole idea like what will
be the comparison between all these two
bikes and which bike it will be easy for
you to select all right then now moving
on to prompt number four which is I want
you to act as an expert in so expanding
on the act as a prompt you have the
option to provide Bing chat with more
specific instructions regarding the role
you wanted to assume this feature proves
particularly beneficial when dealing
with technical subjects for instance if
you wish to leverage Bing chat's
assistance in initiating your Learning
Journey of JavaScript let's say you can
specify its rule by stating I would like
to act as an X code in JavaScript with
five years of experience right from the
start by doing so you establish the
desired context and provide Bing chat
with relevant background information
enabling it to better understand the
respond to queries you will be posing
all right now let's try this prompt I
won't
you this egg
as an expert
in JavaScript
let's see how it responds
all right I think we have to write the
complete thing so I want
you to act as an
expert in JavaScript
I have no
prior experience
all right
and please
suggest me
a syllabus
right now let's say
if you click on this
now let's see how big chat will respond
all right
so it is creating a syllabus and it is
also mentioning the links as we can see
all right
so it is also helpful if you want to
learn or want to create a syllabus or
study plan or roadmap
for an interview or if you want to
prepare for something this prompt is
very helpful for you guys so there are
many more examples of prompts you have
to explore that and now let's move on to
the next topic does Bing use chat GPT
Bing does not utilize chat GPT for its
chatbot but instead employs gpd4 in
formulation of its responses currently
the new Bing is the only means of
accessing gpt4 for free according to
Microsoft the integration of the latest
language model enhances Bing's power and
accuracy beyond that of chat GPT in
other words Bing's chatbot uses a more
advanced language model that is not
available in other chatbots including
chat GPT so with that let's talk about
our post Gadget program in Ai and
machine learning so if you are ready to
unlock the potential of artificial
intelligence and machine learning join
our comprehensive program designed to
equip you with the skills and knowledge
needed to excel in this Dynamic field
this Ai and machine learning course is
designed to enhance your career in Ai
and ml by clarifying Concepts like
machine learning deep learning
reinforcement learning and more you'll
have the access to four live sessions
led by industry experts covering the
latest advancements in AI such as
generative modeling chat jpt open Ai and
chat Bots all right friends with that we
have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really helped you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign